mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour les français ont donc ratifié
les français ont donc ratifié l'entrée
de la grande bretagne et trois autres
candidates dans le marché commun les
résultats du référendum ont toutefois
quelque peu déçu les partenaires de la
france notamment du fait d abstention
qui sont proches de 40 % 40 % auxquels
il faut ajouter 7 % de votes blancs et
nuls vous avez sans doute suivi hier la
télévision la longue soirée consacrée
aux résultats et aux commentaires sur ce
référendum
je crois d'ailleurs qu'il faut rappeler
notre opération estimation qui a pas
fait parfaitement marché puisque à 20h
pile vous le voyez sur ce studio sur ce
tableau du studio 4
nous vous donnions des chiffres qui
étaient pratiquement les chiffres
définitifs
inutile de dire que les commentaires ce
matin avant bon train et se poursuivent
et que les interprétations sont
quelquefois différentes selon les camps
politiques il suffit pour cela de jeter
un coup d'oeil à la première page des
journaux avec un peu un peu plus de
recul maintenant ce matin on peut tout
de même essayer d'analyser calmement
geek laisse ce scrutin du dimanche 23
avril comme vous allez le souligner il
ya d'abord un fait acquis sur lequel
personne ne veut plus revenir parce qu
il a en quelque sorte force de loi c'est
que les français ont ratifié
élargissement de la communauté c'est à
dire l'entrée de la grande bretagne de
l'irlande de la norvège et du danemark
dans le marché commun par une majorité
d'un peu plus des deux tiers des ouïes
compte un tiers de non à peine par
rapport aux suffrages exprimés
légalement c'est cela qui compte c'est
la première conclusion que l'on en tire
est d hier soir du côté du gouvernement
et du côté de la majorité le premier
ministre puis le mise à l'intérieur
n'ont pas manqué de souligner en ce sens
on peut dire que l'objectif de ce
référendum a été atteint reste
évidemment la manière par laquelle ce
résultat a été atteint
et là bien sûr c'est là qu'on n'est plus
d'accord selon qu'on était partisan du
oui ou du non où de l'abstention
monsieur chaban-delmas hier soir
estimait que le pourcentage de
participation un peu plus de 60% était
somme toute satisfaisant dans la mesure
où il est bien connu
que les problèmes de politique étrangère
n'ont jamais beaucoup passionné les
français
considérant d'autre part que les
abstentionnistes ne sont pas a priori
tous des gens hostiles à l'europe
monsieur chaban-delmas estime qu'en fin
de compte seuls les électeurs ayant voté
non soit 17,13 % des inscrits ne voulait
pas de l'europe c'est-à-dire en fait
moins d'un français sur cinq
ce à quoi les partisans du non comme
monsieur georges marchais et les
communistes répondent qu'à peine plus
d'un tiers des français 35 5% des
inscrits ont approuvé la politique
européenne du président pompidou c'est
une querelle de chiffres classique à
laquelle nous sommes tous bien habite
quant aux partisans de l'abstention ou
le vote blanc c'est à dire les
socialistes de monsieur mitterrand
le psu de monsieur rocard ils estiment
que leurs résultats représentent un nom
au gouvernement sans pour autant
condamner l'europe ni refuser son
élargissement
mais si l'on regarde les chiffres on
constate que le nombre des wii n'est pas
très loin du score réalisé par monsieur
georges pompidou au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle de 1969 les
dirigeants de la majorité en conclut que
le renfort des centristes réformateur
n'a pas servi à grand chose voire à rien
pas du tout rétorque bien sûr messieurs
jean lecanuet et jean-jacques
servan-schreiber sans nous le référendum
aurait tourné au désastre
comme toujours ces réactions des partis
ne sont ni tout à fait fausses ni tout à
fait exact en analysant sérieusement les
résultats avec les spécialistes de la
sofres nous ont permis hier soir de
faire cette estimation
eh bien nous avons nous constaté que les
électeurs réformateurs
c'était en fait partager entre le oui et
l'abstention avec toutefois un
pourcentage d'abstention nettement plus
élevé que la moyenne il ya bien donc une
défection d'un grand nombre de ses
électeurs centristes réformateur mais on
a constaté aussi qu'il y avait eu des
défections dans le camp des électeurs de
la majorité 10 à 15% et notamment à lui
dr donc là aussi il ya une querelle qui
n'est pas définitivement tranché
les communistes pour leur part retrouve
avec le nom les voix recueillies à peu
de choses près par monsieur jacques
duclos en 1969
mais ça ne veut pas dire que tous les
électeurs communistes et voté non en
fait l'analyse révèle qu environ 15 %
d'entre eux se sont abstenus
alors d'où viennent les noms
supplémentaires eh bien ils viennent
pour la plupart
part de quelques ultras nationalistes
anti-européens mais surtout de
mécontents qui ont profité de l'occasion
pour dire non au gouvernement
et cela paraît très particulier très
très très évidemment dans les régions
qui connaissent d'assez sérieuses
difficultés économiques restent et enfin
à analyser l'abstention qui a été le
phénomène le plus remarquable de ce
scrutin car en fait c'est le plus fort
pourcentage d'abstention on n'est jamais
enregistrée depuis que le suffrage
universel a été institué en france c'est
à dire depuis 1848
il ya pour analyser l'abstention j'ai
fait appel à un spécialiste alain
lancelot professeur à l'institut
d'études politiques et auteur d'un livre
intitulé l'abstentionniste électorales
en france alain lancelot l'abstention
est un phénomène qui est toujours un peu
difficile à analyser néanmoins est ce
que pouvait dégager des grands courants
dans cette masse la sioniste
hier il ya eu si l'on ajoute les
abstentions et les votes nuls 13
millions 700 mille le personnes qui
n'ont pas voté ou qui ont refusé de
voter ou de s'exprimer et dans un
suffrage y ait là dessus il y en a 6 à 7
millions qui sont des abstentions qu'on
pouvait attendre parce que il ya
généralement un niveau d'abstention et
les votes nuls de ceux de cette
importance ça veut dire qu'il n'a que
fait plus que d'habitude et c'est
peut-être ça qui pose problème
alors ya toutes sortes
d'abstentionnistes est ce qu'il ya des
gaullistes anti européen sans doute des
européens antigaulliste comment peut-on
démêler tous mt puis il semble qu'il ya
effectivement dans les abstentions
supplémentaire celle que qu'on attendait
peut-être pas aussi nombreuses
il y à au moins trois courants il ya un
premier courant qui est celle celui des
des gens qui sont vos listes mais qui
sont anti européen il ya un second
courant qui est celui de ceux qui sont
européens
mais antigaulliste des socialistes par
écrit socialiste par exemple et puis il
ya un troisième courant qui est le
courant de ce qu'ils pensaient que la
consultation du gpra c'est dramatique
parce que le suspense n'était pas assez
grand qui donneront pas été mobilisés et
nous passe étaient mobilisés le problème
le plus difficile est de savoir qui est
qui surtout lorsqu'il s'agit d'un
comportement qui par définition n'est
pas exprimé alors est ce qu'on peut ces
deux chiffres et ces trois courants les
gaullistes d'anti européen par exemple
est ce que ça représente beaucoup
monde je pense que ça ne représente pas
beaucoup de monde il y en a certainement
une petite partie d'ailleurs qui ont
voté non également ce ne doit pas
représenter beaucoup de monde parce que
les sondages nous montre bien que
l'europe et l'élargissement de la
communauté européenne est généralement
admis et que le ralliement ou en tout
cas l'affirmation par le président
pompidou de sa vocation européenne ou de
son tendance européenne est généralement
très bien reçue par son électorat
donc il est peu probable que ce courant
sur l'important alors deuxième courant
les européens antigaulliste la gauche
non communiste en eau alors ce coût est
évidemment beaucoup plus important je
crois qu'il est impossible de porter au
crédit des amis de monsieur mitterrand
de monsieur rocard le total de
l'augmentation de l'abstention est
d'ailleurs monsieur mitterrand lui-même
s'est bien gardé de le faire parce que
si on regarde géographiquement la
répartition des abstentions on voit que
ce n'est pas directement liée à
l'implantation du parti socialiste qu'il
y à des endroits où le parti socialiste
est bien implantée et où l'augmentation
des abstentions n'est pas anormalement
fortes et qu'inversement elle est très
forte là où il n'est pas très bien
implanté normand est ce qu'on peut
risquer un chiffre un pourcentage à
attribuer précisément à la gauche non
communiste et bien pour la tribu il faut
peut-être au fond commencer par
s'interroger sur le troisième courant
parce que le troisième congé celui des
rangs des électeurs sans passion
céréales tin tous les électorats même
des électeurs gaulliste certainement pas
atteint tous les électorats
mais c'est ce n'est pas la première fois
dans l'histoire électorale qui a une
élection qui ne souhaitent pas beaucoup
de passion ce serait tout de même
extraordinaire que en un siècle est déjà
plus d'un siècle de suffrage universel
sur la première action sans passion or
jusqu'à maintenant les élections sans
passion non jamais entraîné un taux de
refus aussi important en général ça se
tient au maximum autour de 32 33 % pour
cette fois ci on obtient 47%
j'en conclus donc que il doit y avoir
environ 15% des électeurs inscrits qui
sont des électeurs qui refusent
politiquement de s'exprimer sur ce
référendum sur les consignes qui leur
ont été fournis par françois mitterrand
et michel rocard
chez nos voisins européens les réactions
sont assez mitigés bien sûr on est on
est satisfait de voir ce traité
d'adhésion ratifié par les français la
france est d'ailleurs là
première à le faire mais dans les
milieux européens il est même certaine
déception devant l'ampleur des
abstentions précisément lié aujourd'hui
à luxembourg une réunion des ministres
des affaires étrangères des disques
pense-t-on là bas de ce référendum
pensant riquewihr
eh bien disons le franchement on
s'attendait à mieux ici à luxembourg où
les dix ministres des affaires
étrangères les 6 du marché comme un plus
les quatre nouveaux membres sont
actuellement réunis ici pour préparer la
conférence sommet qui aura lieu en
octobre prochain à paris
on s'attendait à mieux que ce record
absolu d'indifférence à mieux que ce oui
du bout des lèvres à une question qui
intéresse au premier chef
l'avenir des français mais non se
console en se disant qu'après tout la
journée d'hier a été nettement meilleur
pour l'europe qu'elle n'a été pour
monsieur georges pompidou sur un plan
tout au moins technique puisque les
français ont dit oui à l'entrée des
quatre nouveaux membres cela dit on ici
l'essentiel
et puis ici à luxembourg on comptabilise
volontiers dans le camp des voix
pro-européenne un certain nombre
d'abstentionnisme tous ceux qui comme
les socialistes ont fait passer leur
opposition au régime avant leur foi
européenne après tout du temps un
français sur six seulement a vraiment
dit non qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire votre
avis pour rendre l'europe plus
populaires qu'elle met à
nous devons faire les choses qui sont
compris par dix ans les citoyens et
pendant pas seulement parler de dison de
toutes les questions monétaires
difficile économique financier
rapidement il faut le faire s'il ya tant
de choses qui sont plus intéressant
directement pour le citoyen et c'est
pour cet égard que la commission fera 7
1 proposition lesquelles par exemple
d'abord nous voulons qu'un délai assez
court il y a dix rangs l'heure toute la
liberté de notre communauté d'aller le
lendemain vers puis à l'autre charneux
document chaque contrôle à la frontière
alors que les personnes peuvent pas
voyager à l'intérieur de la communauté
des dix sans que l'on connaisse encore
les frontières
deuxièmement nous sommes d'avis que il
faut savoir un délai court aussi le
libre est censément de notre communauté
que tout le monde a le droit de prendre
chez son enseignement visiter et ses
trains steve
tertio nous sommes d'avis aussi en ce
qui concerne le citoyen entre rencontres
qu'il y a des millions de migrants dans
notre communauté qui travaillent ici et
là que ceux qui sont déjà un certain
temps dans une belle 7ème place c'est un
promu en droit d'accéder aux 6 7 3 2
et l'action cela veut dire et penser que
s'exprimer sur le plan local
comment s'est passé la nuit en fait si
bien maintenant avec mes collègues
européens et maintenant la page est
tournée en avant l'europe est une
création continue pour les vieux
monsieur mansholt pense qu'il faut tirer
des conclusions du demi échec du
référendum français qu'il faut prendre
des mesures pour rendre l'europe plus
populaire plus humaine pour la retirer
aux spécialistes qui dans des
discussions abstraites comme celle qui
se passe ici font actuellement l'europe
monsieur schumann pense au contraire que
la page est tournée qu'il faut
maintenant parler d'autre chose
il est en tout cas des gens qui sont
relativement satisfaits ici de la
timidité du oui français se sont tous
ceux qui pensaient qu un oui massif
aurait donné prétexte à votre pays pour
parler un peu haut à la table des
conférences
'cela dit on de façon à que cruelle un
risque qui est maintenant de tout voir
écartés informations première à vous
parie aussi une autre conséquence
intéressante à suivre après cette
consultation dès hier dimanche et 23
avril ce référendum c'est celle de la
bourse de paris qui était depuis
quelques temps déjà dans une période
d'optimisme comment les boursiers
réagissent t-il aujourd'hui j'avais
d'abord la réaction a été très modérée
aujourd'hui disons qu'il ya une moitié
de valeurs françaises qui a baissé avec
des écarts très faibles inférieurs à 1%
il ya des titres qui se sont maintenus à
leurs niveaux de vendredi qui ont même
progressé c'est le cas par exemple de
michelin alors est-ce que la bourse va
être gagné par l'abstention c'est à dire
est-ce qu'il va y avoir un
ralentissement des affaires
c'est peut-être le signe le plus net ce
matin tout au moins il y avait moins de
transactions mais je crois qu'il ne faut
pas de tirer et tirer de conclusion de
ce ralentissement des affaires car il
est évident que le référendum n'a pas de
réaction sur la situation économique en
france
et puis deuxièmement la bourse de paris
attire toujours les capitaux étrangers
je termine en signalant que et ce au
standard était réservé à la cotation ce
matin
en effet hier un forage à lannemezan
a permis de mettre en évidence une
découverte de gaz naturel on se retrouve
tout à l'heure j'ai robe blanche pour
les cotations encore un mot à propos du
référendum il s'agit d'un épisode
dramatique ce jeune homme s'appelle
michel la broche il a 29 ans il avait 29
ans il a été tué hier dans des
circonstances assez troubles c'est un un
militant communiste
c'est évidemment l'incident le plus
grave qui entourait ce référendum et
hier matin très tôt il gardait les
panneaux électoraux à hirson dans
l'aisne une voiture a quitté
délibérément le côté droit de la route
et s'est jetée sur lui michel labrosse a
été tué le conducteur de l'automobile
s'est constitué prisonnier est un
militaire de carrière de 25 ans est
évident que cet aspect dramatique de la
campagne électorale risque d'alimenter
de nouvelles polémiques
l'autre grand évènement de la soirée
d'hier il s'agit évidemment du retour
des cosmonautes d'apollo 16 après une
dernière marche
young et duke ont quitté la lune en
emportant avec eux plus de 100 kg
d'échantillons le décollage s'est
parfaitement bien passé ils ont
maintenant retrouvé
mattingly leurs camarades qui devait
commencer à s'ennuyer à tourner autour
de la terre en tout cas les dernières
heures encore été l'occasion d' images
magnifiques transmise de la une des
images qu'on avait eu tellement
l'occasion de voir à cause justement du
référendum français parce que les vols à
poule où sont planifiés en fonction de
considérations astronomiques et pas de
l'actualité politique et nous avons reçu
tout même des images magnifiques on a pu
le mener que peu en direct et georges
leclercq a monté les séquences les plus
intéressantes de cette merveilleuse
épopée de cet avant dernier numéro de
l'épopée lunaire avant une coupure du de
10 ou 15 ans ne l'oublions pas regarder
il était dans un terrain très difficile
très vallonné où les foyers qui monte et
qui disparaissent dans ce terrain scarpe
et avec ses gros aiguille noir qui
explore ils ont donc effectivement
rapporté de la lune exactement 111 kg
sens qui nous d'roches ça ne vous dit
peut-être rien c'est plus que n'en avait
rapporté ensemble les astronautes
d'apollo 11 d'apollo douchez d'apollo 14
et 35 kg de plus que ceux d'après aucun
c'est vous dire le travail qu'ils ont
accompli ils ont un caillou de 18 kg
comme on comprend l'impatience des
géologues de rock
dexia malheureusement il semble qu'il
n'ait pas d'anorthosite la note positive
dit pas grand chose c'est ce sont des
roches cristallines que l'on suppose
être les roche de la croûte originel de
la lune on pensait en trouver des
morceaux qui aurait été projeté là et
bien championnat pas beaucoup trouvaient
regarder les maintenant au pied de ce
merveilleux rocher cet éboulis énorme en
bonne condition que ça soit sur tes
enfants des reportages sauveteurs qui
sont bons cela absolument et vous allez
voir tout à l'heure l'image la plus
étonnante la poursuite du lem dans
l'espace mais pour le moment restons là
regardons ces images fantastiques de
naturel vraiment dans les films de
science fiction studio je crois qu'on
n'avait pas une meilleure qualité plus
du côté est certainement
on avait beaucoup moins d'émotion nantes
posent leurs semblables dur voyez comme
il s'enfonce comme maintenant avec ces
combinaisons ils ont la maîtrise du
terrain vraiment là on avait faim à
saint bien équipé pour l'exploration de
la lune voyait toujours leur pas blanc
sur ce sol cris et tous ces
affleurements de rochers si blizzard des
roches donc généralement assez
inconsistant des prêches du rigoles hits
comme ils disent et non pas ses peines
roches cristallines et ont dû se faire
tout au début à la surface de la lune
avant une période de fusion qui ensuite
retravaillé toute cette surface
on n'arrive pas à trouver ces roches de
l'origine gaye 2 4 milliards et demi
d'années voyez ce qu'il met là encore
c'est de la poussière c'est intéressant
mais ce n'est pas sans doute ce qu
aurait voulu les spécialistes et c'est
pourquoi ils ont fait vous allez le voir
son aplomb un gros plan sur cette énorme
rocher pour essayer de l'étudier de le
faire parler à distance
mais de toute façon c'est que le message
des roches lunaires et bien on ne veut
le décrypter que très longuement cours
des travaux de laboratoire et voilà
maintenant le décollage les 17 10
dernières secondes
écoutez regardez
il était 2 heures 26 cette nuit vous
avez vu les panneaux qui viennent de
tomber et à regarder maintenant on fait
de la poursuite en dirigeant la caméra à
380 mille kilomètres de distance et
extraordinaire de la poursuite a duré
fort longtemps et voilà le lem un peu
endommagé vtc panneaux qui sont tombés
aux affections eu beaucoup d'ennuis avec
leurs vêtements que d'ailleurs avant au
moment du rendez-vous deux heures plus
tard ils l'ont beaucoup filmé le lem
pour essayer de comprendre pourquoi il y
avait eu ses ennuis et voilà la même
séquence au ralenti vous voyez à nouveau
c'est pas nous ton qui se détache
il ya un problème l'emballage dilemme
sur vos dires
évidemment c'est une fusée une forme un
peu bizarre mais comme on est dans le
vide on n'a pas besoin d'un
aérodynamisme c'est pourquoi le lem à
cette forme d'assemblage de gwatt à
chaussures et vous découvrez la
la terre la terre donc l'objectif du
retour alors si vous voulez voyons un
peu ce qu'ils vont faire maintenant ils
font donc travailler car il travaille en
orbite autour de la lune ne l'oublions
pas oui malheureusement l'expérience
orbitales autour de la lune a été
raccourcie d'un d'une journée pour
accélérer le retour et c'est bien
dommage car elle est très importante ce
soir ils vont à 21h50 se séparer du lem
qu'ils vont précipiter vous savez sur la
lune pour faire une expérience de
sismologie qu'ils vont lancer un petit
satellite de 36 kg et enfin à 3h25
ils les allume le moteur du vaisseau
apollo pour revenir sur terre
instant crucial on est optimiste car
hier soir matignon a allumé son moteur
pour changer le plan de son orbite et
tout s'est bien passé
tout devrait donc bien se passer ce soir
ils quitteront en orbite lunaire et ses
jeudis à 20h40 deux kills amerrir on
dans le pacifique devant nos caméras et
devant vos écrans
reste-t-il encore une toute petite
inquiétude après les incidents de dol
dinan pour sa taupe et bien comme à deux
reprises le vaisseau apollo été mis à
feu a bien marché du zinc maintenant
spears marchèrent du suspense quand il
n'y a pas le nom maintenant on est très
confiant le reste de l'actualité à
l'étranger deux grands titres élection
partielle en allemagne fédérale et le
vietnam avec deux séries engagement dans
la région des hauts plateaux en
allemagne monsieur willy brandt a dû
suivre avec une certaine inquiétude hier
les résultats des élections dans le
bade-würtemberg des élections qui
revêtait une importance nationale
puisqu'elle s'est déroulé à moins d'un
mois de la discussion devant le
parlement des traités avec moscou et
varsovie
à ce moment là c'est véritablement toute
la politique d'ouverture à l'est du
chancelier willy brandt qui sera en
cours
hier donc six millions d'électeurs ouest
allemands étaient appelés à se rendre
aux urnes
et il s'est agit effectivement d'une
victoire incontestable des adversaires
de monsieur brand c'est à dire les
chrétiens-démocrates de monsieur barzel
monsieur barzel qui est lui-même
candidat chancelier la cd ou en effet
remporté 53 % des voix et 65
des 120 sièges de ce parlement régional
et puis décidément le chancelier brandt
n'a pas eu de chance au cours de ces 24
heures puisqu'il ya eu aussi la
défection d'un député libéral ce qui
fait que maintenant le chancelier ne
dispose plus que de 249 voix au
bundestag c'est à dire exactement le
minimum pour conserver la majorité au
vietnam
l'offensive des communistes se poursuit
sur tous les fronts particulièrement sur
les hauts plateaux et aussi au nord de
saigon autour de la ville d'ann log dont
on parle déjà depuis plusieurs jours sur
la nationale 13 qui relie cette ville à
la capitale du vietnam yen il ya
toujours d'importants mouvements de
troupes
c'est un va-et-vient d'armement et de
tanks qui monte vers le nord et de
refuge et vous voyez ici qui descendent
vers le sud la bataille pour anloc dure
maintenant depuis plus de deux semaines
et la ville a subi de nouvelles attaques
hier pendant ce temps là les
nord-vietnamiens au cours de ces
dernières heures ont accentué leur
poussée sur le front des hauts plateaux
plusieurs boss sud vietnamiennes sont
tombés et les combats font rage autour
de tam cannes et de d'actos et puis
hanoi est toujours en alerte des
autorités nord vietnamienne craignent
des bombardements sur la capitale
un b 52 à d'ailleurs été touché au
dessus du nord il ya quelques heures et
a dû faire un atterrissage de fortune
sur la base de dana
à paris ce matin se déroulaient les
obsèques de pierre lazareff sans
discours et sans couronne comme l'avait
voulu
le directeur de francs soit 7 à 9 heures
ce matin qu'a eu lieu à l'hôpital
américain de neuilly la levée du corps
de pierre lazareff
le cortège qui devait se rendre au
cimetière du père lachaise était formée
des parents et des proches
collaborateurs du directeur général de
françois francs soir le journal fondé
par pierre lazareff hollande mana
libération devant lequel ils s'arrêtent
ici une dernière fois
c'est à 10h que le fourgon mortuaire
pénétré dans le cimetière où une foule
nombreuse attendait pour rendre un
dernier hommage aux journalistes
de nombreuses personnalités du monde
politique des hommes de la presse écrite
et télévisée des gens du spectacle était
là pour s'incliner sur la tombe du grand
patron de presse disparu
la cérémonie s'est terminée vers 11h30
elle a eu lieu dans la plus stricte
simplicité sans fleurs sans discours
comme l'avait souhaité pierre lazareff
attends découvert dans les hautes
pyrénées un gisement de gaz aussi
important que celui de l'accès une
question qu'on se pose depuis hier matin
depuis que le gaz jaillit autour d'un
forage sur le plateau de lannemezan la
sonde avait atteint une profondeur de 7
mm ce qui constitue d'ailleurs un record
européen dans ce domaine
selon les premières estimations le débit
journalier de ce forage pourrait
atteindre 500 mille mètres cubes inutile
de dire que les techniciens les
habitants de la région suivaient le
déroulement de ces recherches avec le
plus grand intérêt le temps aujourd'hui
en principe il devrait faire soleil sur
l'ensemble de la france à l'exception de
la moitié sud est du pays décidément les
gens du bord de la méditerranée ne sont
pas gâtés cette année il y aura encore
aujourd'hui là bas des nuages et
quelques pluies orageuses hebdo mais 10
sport nous allons d'abord parler
football à l'abus loin avec le départ
des deux hommes de l'équipe de france au
bourg et les bosquets oui de départ
marcel aubour et bien une titre
définitivement le football il va chez sa
saison à rennes
et puis il retournera à saint tropez à
partir de l'été prochain
quant à bernard bosquet et bien c'est un
départ qui intrigue un peu bernard
dossier était le capitaine de l'équipe
de france contre la roumanie c'était
l'un des hommes de base de georges
boulogne
il ne disputera pas la coupe du monde la
mini coupe du monde au brésil l'été
prochain avec l'équipe de france et
surtout il ne veut plus jouer du tout en
équipe de france c'est un reportage de
jean claude jugement de mars en grand
est ce que vous pensez qu'à 30 ans de
plus en mesure de pouvoir porter le
maillot tricolore
c'est de toute manière on l'est
peut-être en mesure de porter le maillot
tricolore mais je pense que dans la
mesure où
le joueur a des réticences et qui lui
semble qu'il y aura moins à porter
l'équipe de france que ce qu'il a fait
auparavant je pense que ce moment là il
faudrait il faut le laisser
et à ce moment là se tourner vers des
jeunes justement que cet enthousiasme
que j'avais mois auparavant et que j'ai
peut-être un petit peu perdues après de
tous ses matches quel sur le joueur
susceptible de vous remplacer en qualité
de joueur d'une part en qualité de
capitaine d'autre part c'est un
capitaine ça c'est sûr que c'est une
chose
en tant que joueur j'ai pas ce qui est à
moi le joueur qui m'a fait la plus
grosse impression c'est marius trésor
jeux parce que c'est quand même sa place
puisque c'est la place qu'ils occupent
ajaccio et parce que d'ici quelques
quelques temps ce sera le grand patron
de la défense de l'équipe
il n'y a rien entre vous et je vous le
dis on c'est justement ce que j'ai
expliqué monsieur boulogne est ce que je
tiens à dire c'est qu'entre monsieur
boulogne et moi il n'y a rien et ce
n'est pas non plus les derniers
résultats qui peuvent paraître décevant
tu aurais été mauvais pour l'équipe de
france qui m'ont fait prendre cette
décision c'est une décision que j'ai
prise à bien longtemps réfléchi à
l'avance
allez a longuement discuté avec ma forme
de tous ces problèmes mais je veux à
dire qu'entre sur boulogne et moi il n'y
a absolument pas le nombre d'années
toujours espérer qu'il ne s'agisse pas
d'une décision irrévocable autre
chapitre l'athlétisme c'est le grand
démarrage de la saison avec une belle
performance d'ailleurs que la saison
commence mieux pour guy drut oui 13
secondes 3 au 110 m haies pour guide
russe est l'une des meilleures
performances des interclubs hier une
performance de valeur mondiale guide rue
sera l'une des meilleures chances
françaises aux jeux de munich
il al'intention d'ailleurs de disputer
auparavant les championnats des états
unis à seattle pour se mesurent un petit
peu avec les meilleurs américains comme
tous les ans et bien les athlètes
français ont préparé la saison dans les
landes et nous retrouvons claude mais
dieu qui a rendu visite aux stages de
demi-fond à royan au moment des vacances
de pâques
ces deux noms de la côte atlantique sont
synonymes de loisirs et de détente
le beau temps aidant royan était il ya
dix jours la vie de la plus chaude
d'europe avec 22 degrés les athlètes ont
trouvé dans les bungalows de la palmyre
calme et sérénité et ville vers 10hoo
diriger le stage d athlète de demi fond
qui ont bien voulu venir s'entraîner à
la palmyre à côté de royan javel vous
nous disiez un petit peu comment se
déroule ce stage qu'est ce que l'on fait
tout au long de la journée
et si les appels qui sont là vous donne
satisfaction quant au sérieux de leur
entraînement et bien oui sérieux
d'entraînement tous l'ont évidemment
mais il y avait surtout ici pour se
détendre parce qu'il faut comprendre
aussi que c'est une transition entre la
préparation hivernale et la préparation
estivale
et si on doit vous décrire une journée
ici ils sont occupés durant toute cette
journée à partir de 8h à 8h30 nous avons
un petit déjeuner une heure après ils
partent pour le travail le plus souvent
la nature car nous avons quand même la
possibilité aussi d'utiliser
et l'hippodrome de la palmyre les
meilleurs athlètes du demi fond français
sont réunis là pour les conseiller
robert bobin a demandé au meilleur
entraîneur d'être présent mais chacun
est tout de même livre de mener son
entraînement comme bon lui semble et
même pour boxberger une partie de tennis
avec sa femme n'est pas une chose
interdite avant l'entraînement sous bois
le déjeuner pris en commun à pontaillac
à 12 ans 30 très précises
l'après-midi sieste puis de nouveaux
entraînements de nous vendre un an à
partir de 16 heures jusqu'à 18 heures
suivant évidemment le travail qui sont à
accomplir
le jour de notre passage à royan les
coureurs de 800 m meyer sanchez gonzalez
avait décidé d'aller passer leurs
moments de détente au zoo animée par
monsieur caillé amis des animaux qui va
lui-même capturer ses propres bêtes en
asie ou en afrique
l'athlète le plus téméraire tout ça qui
n'est pas effrayé par le piton jacky
boxberger où en êtes-vous de votre
entraînement et de votre préparation en
vue de munich car au fond c'est vraiment
le but de la saison mais maintenant je
vais terminer mon gros kilométrages j'ai
fait entre ici j'ai fait entre 35 et 40
km chez moi je faisais entre 20 et 25
maintenant je vais arrêter le
kilométrage je vais en faire encore un
peu mais je vais maintenant basé sur la
vitesse résistance spécifique
jean wadoux habituellement vous nous
valait une grande performance
moi de juger vos 3,34 record d'europe du
15 s'en va tu es ce que vous préparez
également quelque chose pour le match
contre l'allemagne est démocratique
non pas du tout parce que je crois que
il est très difficile d'avoir deux
sommets en demi fond dans l'année
l'exemple d'helsinki l'a encore prouvé
et je crois que si l'on veut être bien
très bien même en septembre il faut tout
axer sur septembre on ne peut pas avoir
deux sommets dans l'année on ne peut pas
avoir deux fois une fraîcheur qui permet
de faire de grandes performances
la bourse de paris maintenant les
cotations en compagnie de gérard vidal
hanche
oui oui nous allons gagner tout de suite
la corbeille des agents vous allez voir
donc les grandes valeurs françaises
les écarts sont vraiment très mauvaise
banque de l'indochine de francs - 1
financière de paris a ouvert en légère
baisse vous voyez sur reprend ensuite
une séance
la compagnie générale d'électricité
c'est peut-être un petit peu plus
sensible mais vraiment on peut pas dire
que les baisses le soit très
significatif michelin avait même ouvert
15 105 francs mieux en ce qui concerne
la thomson le groupe thomson puisqu'il
ya la société mr thompson brand et la
fille comme seul csn on connaît
maintenant les résultats ils sont assez
bons puisque le dividende de thomson
brand sera majoré de 15% 690 contre six
francs et à thomson csf 3 francs 25
contre 250 une augmentation de 30% de
poulenc en légère baisse donc même les
grandes valeurs chimiques sont très
résistantes bsn annonce ce matin un
dividende de 21 francs au lieu de 19
donc une majoration de 10% alors que
citroën maintient son cours de vendredi
dans l'industrie des boissons c'est
maintenant officiel perrier va prendre
une participation de 30% dans la firme
italienne san pellegrino
cette prise de participation sera
concrétisée par un vote à l'assemblée
des actionnaires italiens le 29 avril et
voici tout de suite le cours baisse au
standard qui vient juste juste inscrire
car quand je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
il n'a pas été coté à l'ouverture c'est
à 13h30 que le premier cours a été
établie n'est pas encore souligné donc
c'est pas un cours définitifs 167 francs
c'est une chose qui dépasse 10%
aujourd'hui comme on vous l'a dit tout à
l'heure c'est une découverte de
gas quand on ne connaît pas encore bien
sûr l'importance il faudra d'autres
essais de production
mais ce qui est déjà confirmée c'est que
ce gaz est propre
c'est un gaz sans soufre bhv en prend
aux mains se maintient assez facilement
c'est surtout olida sur ce tableau alors
qu'il fallait voir le coup en effet
olida à est très recherchée car il ya
actuellement une liste de majorité et ce
titre a monté de 20 le % depuis quelques
séances de leurs étrangères peu des kawa
si le cours d'eau nida 465 en 440 et
voilà pour la bourse de paris
les temps et les transactions sur l'or
ne se sont pas enflammés aujourd'hui ce
sont les mêmes cours 7890 qu'entre 7885
pour le lingot et le napoléon 61 francs
50 avoue jean-michel des jeunes merci
gérard le saint du jour avant de
terminer cette édition de télé midi
saint fidèle il est né au xvième siècle
en allemagne par la suite il devient
avocat à colmar et depuis la ensuite il
entre chez les capucins c'était un grand
prédicateur paraît-il un martyr lui
aussi victime des guerres de religion
demain c'est la saint-marc bonne femme
bonne fête aux fidèles aux marques et
aux jean-marc bonne journée à tous